we went from zero dollars to four point
four million dollars per month in 20
months and it also sucked it got so bad
that Layla and I and my wife were
walking one day and she says let's just
shut this thing down I was like wait
hold on this might be worth something so
I called an investment banking friend of
mine and I said hey if I were to sell my
business like do you think I could get
anything for it and he's like oh
I was like wow that sounds amazing he
said wait there's a ton of things wrong
with it that you'd have to fix in order
to get an Institutional Investor to want
to invest the kind of money that you
would want to make an exit so there's
only three variables that are really
going to affect how much a company is
going to be worth one is increasing the
number of customers if all else Remains
the Same if you 10x the number of
customers you will 10x the value of the
business the next is something I call
Lifetime gross profit and so if I want
to make more money I'll either have to
get more customers or make them worth
more so then what's the third variable
you divide that by risk those are the
three variables that you have to
increase or decrease the value of a
company